Introducing the director of this documentary.
Sabaah follow Jaan.
Okay.
How are you?
Thank you everyone for coming and taking the time out of your busy day.
I'm sure everybody has lots to do,
so it's great to see you all.
[inaudible]
so before we jump into the movie,
I've just got a few contexts that in questions and I think would help kind of
inform the audience about bit about who you are and how some of these things
started.
Um,
I understand that you are from,
uh,
southern California,
south central Los Angeles to be exact.
Can you talk a little bit about your upbringing and how your upbringing against
the backdrop of the 1992 riots shaped some of your outlook for this movie?
Yeah.
Um,
so I was born and raised on 41st and figure out what,
which is very close to USC.
It's probably to USC what Harlan would be to Columbia in a sense of kind of
being two different worlds right next to each other.
And so the riots happened.
I was two years old.
I don't really remember much,
but when I was four,
my mom moved us to Hawaii where we lived until I was about nine years old.
So for that little period of my childhood,
I grew up using rainwater,
solar power,
you know,
eating from the land,
just being really connected to nature and for my mom,
I think that was her way of trying to give me a better life.
I was homeschooled during that time,
you know,
she wanted to find something that was different than the options that were
available when you're a mom in south central La.
So when I came back to the mainland,
I remember very clearly I started public school and about the second grade and I
was so disturbed by segregation and it was so obvious to me because I had kind
of been in this,
you know,
outside context and I was like,
why is it the other people who are picking up the trash are brown and all the
people who drive nice cars are white.
And you know,
these things were just very jarring to me because I hadn't really seen them.
I hadn't really grown up thinking that that was normal.
And so,
um,
you know,
as I got older I kind of thought that the way that I would make a difference was
to become a doctor,
be a successful person,
you know,
eventually one day give back to my community.
So I,
uh,
graduated from Columbia in 2013 and I was premed there.
I took the MCAT,
I was working at a nonprofit that did reentry,
working with people who are incarcerated to try to help them get their lives
back together.
And,
um,
you know,
medicine just wasn't really speaking to me.
My brother's a doctor and he was going through the process and loving it and
feeling fulfilled and feeling like he was moving toward his goals.
And I was kind of forcing myself along trying to be this person,
trying to be this kind of savior kid that I thought I had to be.
So when Mike Brown was killed,
um,
it really just called to something like really deep inside of me and all of
those questions that I had about my path and about how I could get involved in
this kind of idea that I would,
you know,
be a doctor and make scholarships for kids and maybe one day,
like write a book that someone would find it turned into a movie.
Um,
you know,
all that seems so silly in comparison to this life or death situation.
And it was like,
you know,
you can't,
I just felt like I couldn't sit it out.
So I got to Ferguson about a month after Mike Brown was killed actually with one
of your fellow Googlers,
Jayna London,
who's here.
Um,
we went,
we were actually just doing community service.
I wanted to interview people at the protest to show that there was going to be a
longterm traumatic effect and try to look at it from a public health approach
because those were the sort of skills that I had at the time.
And then really quickly,
it kind of grew larger than that.
And those little,
my little pamphlets were not really useful.
It's the middle of the night and there's tear gas and pepper spray flying.
So that's how we sort of organically just started rolling and asking questions.
Got It.
So you and your code director,
Damon Davis,
uh,
you had never worked together before.
No.
Um,
in fact you would never even met.
Can you talk us through how you two met and decided that you wanted to make a
movie together?
Hmm.
Yeah.
So about two weeks after we got out there,
we started filming and we knew we had to see it through and we didn't know what
format it was going to be in.
We didn't know if it was going to be,
you know,
some kind of ongoing thing where we're putting out short bursts and trying to
give like a counter news narrative.
But then we couldn't keep up with that cycle.
And I'm,
Damon was somebody who is really well respected in Saint Louis visual artists.
He's got work in the Smithsonian.
He recently had an exhibit at the was just like really all around bright and
artistic,
artistic person.
So once we decided it needed to be a feature,
we decided that we needed to work with someone who was from there because we
didn't want to make a movie that showed this place as though this was always how
it was,
you know,
like it seemed like this whole city of Saint Louis got to reduce to got reduced
this moment in Ferguson.
And so we wanted to work with someone who could take us deeper than what we were
already seeing.
Um,
and we kind of just started putting feelers out and Damon's name kept coming
back.
Damon Damon Damon,
till about three months in,
we connected and you know,
he came on,
he's such a professional artist and strong person.
He was like,
okay,
so I'm going to come on board,
but I have to direct this.
And I was like,
well,
I'm working on this for a couple months but maybe we can,
you know,
share and,
and I was really glad that he did kind of assert himself in that way because he
was such a mentor to me as far as how to be a professional artist,
how to protect your ideas.
And your subjectivity while still trying to sell your product.
And um,
you know,
just has always been so clear and so committed and also brought that level of
accountability that it seemed like other media outlets really didn't have in the
way that they were reporting the story.
Got It.
So you talked about Damon and in the fact that he's from the Ferguson area,
can you talk to me a little bit more about how important it is to have an
African American man from Ferguson as well as you as an African American woman
telling this story about what happened?
I think it's really,
really important.
Um,
you know,
the fact that we're a man and a woman,
what we didn't really touch on directly in this film,
but that,
you know,
I'm sure everyone is familiar with is a lot of that tension,
that gendered tension that happens within social justice movements.
Um,
where,
you know,
typically it's kind of the CIS Hetero Lens that says anybody who's outside of
that identity,
if they're advocating for themselves,
they're taking away from the greater good.
They're taking away from the real issue.
And so that was definitely at play here.
And we try to counteract it by just representing these different lanes and
allowing them to sit side by side and showing how none of these people are
really working against each other.
And we also felt like our collaboration was an opportunity to sort of model what
does it look like for people to,
you know,
work through this conditioning that we have worked through these kinds of
issues.
And there definitely were struggles and,
and difficult conversations that had to be had.
Um,
but they meant just always continuously stepped up to the plate.
And I think through our relationship,
I feel like we learned a lot about those tensions and it,
at least for me,
it's been a really critical experience.
Sure.
So in this whole experience,
is there anything that you feel like you learned about yourself?
If you think about a movie,
it always has an arc.
What's your personal arc in the,
the,
the making of this documentary?
Really good question.
Um,
I mean I've learned so much about myself,
but one thing is just,
you know,
it maybe it's a woman thing.
I don't know,
maybe it's me,
but I kind of have had this hesitation about telling people what to do.
So when you're a person with a strong vision whose title is director and is
hesitant to tell people to do,
you know,
it's,
it's tough and also a woman and it's hard.
A lot of times it's hard for men to follow women's lead.
And I don't mean that in a,
in a sense that they're always bigoted,
but I just think that there's something about that there's not,
it's not just like riding a bike for us collectively.
And so just really stepping into that lane as a director and owning authorship
and,
and looking at this film,
you know,
and it's like 80% done and trying to figure out,
okay,
where's my voice in here?
Where am I in here?
And,
and being okay with and being okay with telling my editor know it.
And it has to be this way.
It being okay with pushing back on producers and people who are older than me
and kind of just being centered in the idea that I could have a vision and that
I could see it through and for them that that wasn't wrong.
You know,
there's like a lot of shame that comes along as a woman with,
with exerting are well over a situation when other people disagree.
Um,
and you know,
I don't think that kind of hierarchy is always necessary,
but sometimes in a film process a director has to say this is what it is.
And so just finding the ability to do that and to try to do that graciously and
to sort of accept that,
you know,
you,
you don't always get to be everybody's best friend and the nurturing provider
and also the one who's steering the ship.
And so that was just,
you know,
that's been a learning experience.
Something that I'm still learning and figuring out how to grapple with.
Okay.
So the film has received rave reviews at Sundance.
Congrats.
Thank you.
Um,
talk to us a little bit about the nuts and bolts of how this got made from a
business perspective.
How did you get the financing?
How did it gain attention and traction to be acquired by a major studio?
Yeah.
Um,
I mean a lot of that felt like it was really the universe.
Like a lot of things really just sort of happen in these ways that felt a lot
bigger than us.
And so I credit first and foremost the people of Saint Louis for what they did.
And they created this moment in the situation.
They dramatize this issue in a way that everybody had to pay attention.
Um,
and I also credit the documentary film community are our supporters,
Macarthur Ford,
um,
thresh hold Sundance Tribeca,
firelight media lab,
which is a lab for first and second time they'll makers of color.
I mean really we had no idea until we connected with our first producer Flannery
and she introduced us to fire light and then this kind of floodgate of
documentary funders open and we didn't know that they were there and everyone
was so receptive to the idea.
Two young black first time filmmakers being the ones to tell the story.
And we told them,
you know,
we need x hundred thousand dollars from music licensing and we want to do an
animation that we were gonna do and people continue to respond and continue to
trust us.
And I think,
you know,
it was,
I think it was the strength of the material is the strength of what people were
doing out there.
But it was also sort of,
I think my experience as a go at the Columbia call center,
just kind of making those cold calls and raising that money,
you know,
and not being afraid to ask for what it takes.
And we were talking earlier about project management and a lot of times people
struggle in documentary especially because they don't want to ask for everything
that they need.
They want to figure out a way to minimize it and ask for as little as possible.
And there's a lot of sticker shock and a big part of our strategy,
my strategy was I'm not going to try to do something with less than what I need
to do it.
That's just a set up for failure.
So,
um,
yeah,
was a lot.
It was just a combination I think of of everything coming together at the right
time.
Okay.
So let's start to zoom into the,
the actual movie.
Um,
now that you've made it,
what do you want people to,
to take away from the movie after they've seen it?
I would want people to leave the film feeling shaking and feeling unnerved.
And I don't,
we,
we were really particular not to be prescriptive.
We didn't want to tell people what to think,
how to think exactly what to do next because there is no formula.
There's nobody in the middle of St Louis who can tell some body in this room how
they need to live their life.
But I think in the barrage of information and facts and figures and perspectives
and buzzwords,
we lose sight of what's human about this.
We lose sight of kind of that emotional compass that we have that allows us to
discern and know and feel what's right.
And I think in the context of so much information overload and chaos,
we really wanted to make something that could bring people back to Earth about
it.
Um,
and,
and hopefully be sort of a guidepost to encourage people to move in the right
direction and make the choices that they have to make in their everyday lives
and whatever sacrifices that you know,
may take.
And it will be different for each of us.
You know,
not all of us is going to go and be in the street and make it that particular
sacrifice,
but I think everyone probably every day has an opportunity to make a decision
about where they stand on something important.
Right.
Thank you.
During the movie,
you followed a number of activists.
Why did you select those particular activists and how did you gain their trust?
Um,
so we followed like seven people in depth.
So a lot of the people you see like Kayla,
like Tori,
we've spent a lot of time with them.
Tef Poe and a lot of that didn't make it into the film ultimately because we
only had a certain amount of time.
And David and Brittany stories ended up being the most developed as far as an RF
from beginning to end.
So that was sort of a practical choice.
We really wanted to include as many people as possible and we knew that we were
risking,
um,
from a storytelling perspective,
we knew that that was a technical risk because the more people you include the
last step that you can get in the right amount of time.
But we felt like it was important not to make this into like a MLK Rosa parks
situation where there's one messiah figure who's,
because that's not what it is.
That's not what it was.
And you know,
that's not what the solution is going to look like.
So we followed people who are taking different perspectives from each other.
We've followed people who were bringing something different to the table,
each of them.
We wanted to show that this movement is an ecosystem and that there are myriad
ways that you can participate.
And how did you gain their trust because you followed them.
It's such an intimate way and they had to really put a trusting you to ensure
that you are going to portray them in the most responsible light.
Um,
I think consistency was a big thing at first.
It wasn't there at first.
You know,
we would get them when they were outside and then we would have meetings.
Sometimes they would show,
sometimes they went in and then eventually it got to the point where we could
show up at their house at five o'clock in the morning and film and getting out
of bed.
And so that just took time and consistency.
And you know,
we were always very upfront about where we stood and we weren't out to vilify
anyone in particular.
We were really seeking the humanity in the situation and we were really guided
by the idea that life is precious,
that all life is precious,
that human life is more precious than PR,
than property.
Um,
and I think just that being clear to people by the way,
that we were behaving by the questions that we're asking.
And also having Damon again was a huge part of it because here's someone that
can wake up,
they can go to his house,
you know,
it's not someone just parachuting in and out.
Um,
so yeah,
it was just,
it was an organic process and I think as not being kind of media train probably
helped in that sense because we were really just people.
They are trying to figure out what,
what's going on.
And now that the movie is out,
are you still in touch with any of them?
What's their sense of how the movie came out?
Everyone has been very excited about the movie.
We showed it to them before the premiere.
We had people,
you know,
I don't know if anyone's involved in activism,
but social movements are not always the most fun and friendly.
After a while there's a lot of tension,
a lot of passion.
So we had people who hadn't even been in the room together for over a year who
were thanking us for including them in the same story together and remembering
why they initially got involved.
And that was just,
that was the reward for me.
Like,
even before we had gone to Sundance to have that feedback and to have the people
who made this possible say,
yes,
this is what I lived through.
This is what my experience was like.
Um,
that was just a really powerful feeling.
Yeah.
I Miss President Obama.
True,
true.
I don't even have a question.
I just want to,
there's one point in the documentary where he shown,
and uh,
the quote is something like,
um,
I don't want to seem like I'm putting my thumb on the scale one way or the
other.
What do you think about that?
I know he came under a lot of criticism because people expected him to do so
much more.
Do you think there's anything more that he could have done and what would that
have been?
Um,
know,
I really
cannot imagine what it would be like to have to make presidential decisions.
Um,
I can't imagine where he would have to be weighing in that situation.
But at the end of the day,
you know,
historically the federal government has really been the only protection black
folks have from racism in this country.
So when a president takes a hands on,
hands off approach in the context of the default being racism and there hasn't
been any particular event,
treaty w you know,
reconciliation that I've heard of that would suggest that racism is over.
So not putting your finger on the scale is standing back on a really unbalanced
scale.
And you know,
I don't know what he could have done.
I don't know where he should should've done.
I'm an artist,
I'm not a politician,
but I think he should have done something.
Um,
and I think that by not coming,
I think he really limited his chance to actually understand what was really,
really at play and maybe say something or do something that would have felt more
in touch to the people who were seeing this side of it every day.
Cause he never came.
And I,
and that was a big thing for people in the ground that he never showed up.
He never treated this like a state of emergency.
And it felt like a Katrina.
It felt like one of these events where people were just being abandoned.
And I think in that moment,
you know,
I think everybody's aware of the limitations of the,
of the president.
Nobody thought he was going to swoop in like Batman,
but it would have been great to have some official acknowledgement of this and
kind of elevate the issue rather than,
you know,
he maintained a distance from this movement and as a result of the movement
stayed in this sort of far,
you know,
fringe counter.
So now we're talking about things like the all right in the alt left,
but there's no,
there's absolutely no parallel there,
you know,
so when you don't get that kind of official endorsement,
it just leaves you feeling more vulnerable than ever.
You just finished talking about kind of comparing it to Katrina and when I
looked at it,
um,
there was someone who,
who compared it to the West Bank.
There was a lot of fear,
chaos,
violence and certainty.
Was there any point during the filming of this movie,
particularly since you were so close,
where you felt like that you were in danger?
But yeah,
I always felt that I was in danger.
Um,
and you don't,
and especially as a documentary filmmaker without a press pass and as a black
woman,
you don't get rid of as press.
And so I always had to be really,
really cautious.
It was interesting,
you know,
we have a very diverse team,
so it's interesting being down there with a white or white looking camera man
because he could move in spaces that I couldn't move and he could go behind the
police line and film from over their shoulders.
But it wasn't safe for me to do that.
Um,
I was arrested,
pepper spray,
tear gassed,
you know,
all the different things.
Taunted the police and you know,
and it was very personal at times.
So you had to be careful not to get identified and flagged for,
you know,
next time you were out there.
Um,
you know,
it's,
it's gloves off,
especially when it gets to be nighttime.
And then when the cameras are gone,
it's really gloves off and you feel like you're out there with a bunch of men in
black who have a bunch of toys.
And to them it's a video game.
Like you can,
you can just feel it.
You know,
they're,
they're in their squad,
they've got their commands and there's this some sort of reverie in the air when
they're,
when they're doing this,
when they're kind of bearing down on people like this,
not on behalf of every single cop.
But when you saw the footage of the non indictment and that unified command,
I mean it's still really unclear who those officers were,
what police departments they came from,
whether they were in Saint Louis or from the larger area in Missouri who is
ultimately in control in the chain of command.
So you just have a bunch of people in a completely anonymous black uniforms with
outrageous artillery and you don't even know if something happens,
who would you go to later because there's literally nothing that you can do in
the moment.
So,
um,
it was really terrifying and I really hope that people can read it outside of
the context of a racial dialogue and understand what it means for democracy when
local police have that level of power,
there is no threat to match that,
which means that functionally,
you know,
that stuff is for crowd control.
That stuff is for us when people decide that they don't like what their
government is doing.
And that's really,
really destabilizing to any potential of democracy because just the knowledge
that that's out there discourages people from coming out discourages people from
dissenting.
And all of the most horrible things that have happened in history had been
legal.
It's our responsibility to dissent and to protest when things are are wrong.
That's what we're supposed to do with citizen.
So when you have a forced so powerful that it even negates our capacity to
disrupt if we feel it's necessary,
um,
it's,
it's not a good sign.
And so I hope that people can see that threat.
That's a threat to everyone,
even if they are to the point where they're seeing black folks as part of
everyone yet.
Got It.
One theme that came out in the movie is this whole concept of we're humans.
Um,
you featured many children in the movie all interspersed throughout.
There were many scenes of,
of,
of children.
And to me there's almost nothing more human than kind of being a child.
Was this having many children in the movie?
Purposeful.
And what were you trying to accomplish with that?
Um,
it was purposeful but it was also something that happened really organically and
kind of later in the process.
So I think when we,
when we filmed the last scene,
it was November of 2015 we continue to film until April of the next year.
But we knew in that moment that that was going to be the ending scene of the
film.
And when can I got up there with her mom and with Alexis and did that chant.
I mean you could just feel the energy in there.
There was just something about that that was like,
this is everything that this is about.
And so from there we decided that children were going to be a really big focus.
And then as we look back through the footage and what we had already recorded,
we realized that,
oh my God,
kids are everywhere.
They're watching all of this,
they're absorbing all of this.
And they're just silently and quietly learning about what it means to be a black
person,
what it means to be American,
what you know.
And,
and,
and they also have such clarity even in their kind of immaturity that we felt
like that was the way to remind people that this is a universal story and that
this is something that concerns all of us.
I thought it was very effective.
Um,
so near the end of the documentary,
part of the outcome of this was that there was a DOJ report.
Um,
it showed that
African Americans fundamentally have been treated unfairly for very,
very long time in Ferguson.
Now that the report is out,
do you think anything is going to happen?
I mean,
you know,
this current attorney general revoke the consent decrees.
So that was kind of the point of,
of going the art route is that we didn't feel like these facts and figures we're
going to do anything.
The police chief,
we ended,
we did an interview,
the police chief,
it just didn't make it into the film because he was giving us talking points and
wasn't really weighing in on the meat of what we were trying to get at.
But one thing that he did say was that,
you know,
you can make up facts and figures to prove anything and anyone who really knows
what's going on can look at that report and poke holes in it.
So he had written it off before it was even,
you know,
if I was hot off the presses.
And that is a true statement about facts and figures,
but it doesn't negate the fact that this racism is real.
It doesn't negate the fact that if you ask anybody walking down the street,
probably in any country in America,
any black person will tell you that racism is real.
That is still happening.
And I'll tell you what the experience is like.
And I find myself frustrated constantly.
Every time I see a new study proving what people have been screaming out
forever.
It's like how,
when do we get the benefit of the doubt?
When do we get trusted,
when,
how much is enough?
How much evidence do people see,
how,
how many bodies need to drop on camera before we stop looking for proof that
it's real and start doing something about it.
I think that a lot of these kind of procedures at this point with all that we
already know are,
you know,
are delay tactics and it,
and it's a form of oppression that comes through bureaucracy.
Everything takes so long and it's so slow and it's so complex and it's so
layered that nothing can get done and a lot of the things that need to be done
are really common sense things.
And so we really wanted to,
to encourage people to start thinking with their hearts again and understanding
the limitations of these systems and the ways that we can participate outside of
them and,
and kind of shore up what our administrations are not doing for us.
Another impactful part of the movie to me was there was a female African
American police officer and fundamentally the,
the protesters were telling her that she was on the wrong side and you could see
the emotion in her eyes as if she knew that she was on the wrong side.
Um,
do you have any perspective from African Americans in law enforcement that were
in Ferguson,
even though it may not have been shown on camera?
What was there?
What was there since?
Well,
I think one thing that's really important to remember is we all learn in the
same classroom.
So just because somebody can be the same complexion as me doesn't mean that
they're going to have the same opinions as me.
And it doesn't mean that they're not going to have bought into stereotypes about
what it means to be black.
There's something that happens where we can tell ourselves that we're different
and if we are those few people like someone like me,
I could easily have gone through my life,
you know,
gone and gotten my education,
gone on to become a doctor and said,
why doesn't everybody else just pull up their bootstraps and get it together
like I did.
But I wouldn't have been recognizing,
you know,
the fortune and the luck and the hard work that my mom did and all the people
who had to recognize my potential and all the scholarships and all,
you know,
and so it,
it,
there has not been a cut and dry response across the black law enforcement where
I've spoken to.
But the ones who see the issue do talk about the culture in the locker room.
They do talk about the norms that happened behind closed doors.
They chewed talk about people not taking these training seriously,
showing up to it like,
Oh God,
we have to do this.
And there's that cone of silence because your,
your job is on the line.
Your reputation is on the line.
You know,
sometimes your safety can be online.
As a black police officer,
it really is a catch 22.
And there officers,
even here in New York,
I don't know if anybody has been following this unfolding case about the nearly
a million illegal summons that were issued in New York,
but you know,
there are police officers who had been pushing back on that and a lot of times
they don't get support as whistle blowers.
I think,
you know,
for whatever reason,
I think people of color don't get seen as whistleblowers.
Even when they make these kinds of declarations and they put themselves in
harm's way to talk about this kind of stuff.
They don't get the kind of political cushion that,
uh,
you know,
at Edward Snowden,
Chelsea manning or somebody deep in these systems who comes out with this
information.
They don't get taken like that.
And it's like we wait,
we wait for another study,
we wait for another report.
We wait for a white validated institution to agree that this is real.
Um,
so yeah,
it was,
you know,
would have been terrific I think to get a black cop on camera to talk about this
and to really go there.
But I think that if we search ourselves and imagine what it would be like when
your bread and butter is also something that is systemically compromise and
complicit.
You know,
I think we can imagine what she might've been feeling in that moment.
Right.
Yeah.
One of the quotes from the movie is
this isn't your daddy's civil rights movement.
Can you kind of compare and contrast maybe the 60 [inaudible] civil rights
movement with the civil rights movement that's going on today,
specifically black lives matter.
And maybe tell us what that quote meant to you.
Well,
you know,
the biggest different is one of 'em.
I was alive for him,
one of them I wasn't.
And so in a very literal sense,
you know,
this is our kind of turn in a dark way,
but I think you know,
the biggest evolution,
I think what that quote and that context is referring to is the fact that during
the civil rights movement,
respectability was a tactic was a tool and I think it was effective in certain
ways.
And the,
you know,
the very famous protest,
I am a man,
it was about proving that black people could participate in society in a way
that was above animal.
Because that was,
that's what we were fighting against at that time was the perception that we
were literally inferior,
physically inferior,
you know,
all kinds of crazy eugenics theories and things that,
we're still fighting the strands of those today.
We're still fighting these ideas that there are some inherent inferiority that
black people have.
But at that time,
I can only imagine that would have been very,
very prevalent.
So it would make sense to show up in a suit and say,
I'm a man,
look at my humanity.
You cannot deny my humanity since we've,
we did that.
We came to that conclusion.
Now it's like I don't need to be in a suit.
My pants could be sagging.
You know,
I might be selling a cigarette outside.
I might be,
you know what I'm saying?
I might have a criminal record,
I might be carrying a gun,
but still my life matters still.
The police do not have the right to execute without due process.
Still it is not good enough to say I thought a phone was a gun and that I think
is the leap that is really,
really difficult for Americans of all different races who are in sort of a
middle ground.
It's really,
really difficult for us to take that leap to actually prize the of human life
over decorum over property,
over,
you know,
some sense of fear and to also separate these fears in this kind of boogey man
from what actual black people are.
Because I s w there is no black kid in America who's reaching across a cop's lap
into the window to get a good,
nobody's doing that.
And the fact that that's even believable to people shows that this kind of
specter of what blackness is,
is more present in people's mind and any real idea of what a black everyday
person isn't.
So I think this iteration in the movement is saying you don't have to like us.
You don't have to agree with our demeanor.
You don't have to agree with our tone of voice.
You don't have to agree with our music,
our style of dress,
anything.
You just have to recognize that we are breathing,
that we are standing or hearts are beating,
we have spirits,
we have souls,
we love each other.
We love our family.
That is all the justification and we need to be able to be here and be safe.
There's a saying that you need people on the table and you need people at the
table.
Um,
and I,
I think it kind of means,
you know,
you,
you need people actually approach day,
but then you need people actually at the table working across many different
demographics to impact change.
How do you think that happens in a more scalable way?
What are the concrete reforms that they need to make?
They need to be made to,
uh,
enhance change.
Hmm,
that's tough.
I mean,
I really don't like to talk about things that I'm completely unqualified to talk
about,
but you know,
like in Saint Louis,
Saint Louis is divided up into 91 municipalities.
Ferguson is six miles wide and there are 91 mayors,
91 police chiefs,
91 tax bases,
91 different little tiny pieces that would have to all be reformed in order for
St Louis to be reformed.
And you know,
multiply that times however many cities and each city has a particular set of
issues.
So I think it's about really getting hyperlocal.
I do agree that all solutions are necessary.
I'm very skeptical of politics and politicians,
but I do recognize that there is a need for an organized,
the administration of some sort and there's a need to put pressure to them so
that they make the right choices and decisions.
But I think that,
you know,
there's something to be said for wholesale change and I don't know what that
looks like.
I don't know how long that takes.
But you know,
the fundamental setup of the country is on genocide,
you know,
and,
and that language,
it's in the constitution about white male property owners.
Like just because you added something doesn't mean that that's not there.
You know,
and it doesn't mean that anybody has forgotten.
And as long as that is there,
they're going to be people who feel like that's what it really meant.
That's the original meaning.
That's the original intent.
And so you see these people who feel victimized,
like something has been taken from them.
But if you look at our legal,
you know,
our,
our documents and our history,
it has and they feel that way because we have never invalidated what happened.
We've never said that was wrong.
There has never been an official apology.
There have never been any reparations.
There's never been any redistribution.
And so to think that from that,
from this vastly skewed,
I don't know what the stats are now,
but it was something like at a take a hundred years for the average black family
to catch up to the average white family,
248 years.
Thank you for the average black family to catch up to the average white family.
So if you think there's a reform that's going to do 248 years of work in
anybody's lifetime,
I'd be shocked.
And given the fact that people don't even want it and are not actively seeking
that kind of piece.
Um,
so I think that we just have to be visionary and we have to be brave and,
and you know,
I'm peaceful.
I don't want bloodshed.
I don't want anybody to be hurt.
The whole point is the value of life.
So it's going to take a lot of imagination.
It was going to take a lot of community,
a lot of strength in numbers.
Um,
and we're going to have to figure out something out.
We're going to have to figure out something that hasn't been tried.
What we can't keep leaning on the same structure that brought us to this point
and expecting us to take it,
expecting it to take us in a different direction.
Um,
and I think we do have to recognize too that we are a silent majority and there
are a minority of that silent majority is actually vocal.
But I do firmly believe that most of the people in this country would want for
things to be right or most of the people in the country,
if they understood information better would feel differently.
And so that's something that gives me hope that change is possible.
And I think that unfortunately the dark forces in this country will continue to
push us until we have no choice but to come together and do something.
So I really just try to encourage people to,
to be visionary and to imagine and to know there's so much that we haven't
tried.
There's so many tactics,
there's so much that we can do for one another.
There's so many resources that we can pull out of ourselves.
And you know,
those things kind of just happen in these times.
But I don't know what it takes.
You know,
I really don't,
I can't say that.
I do wish I did.
So in the spirit of sharing,
I feel like you've indulged all of my questions.
I want to open up the floor to anyone who might have questions or to Mike's on
the side.
Um,
could we begin lining if anyone has any questions?
Cause I've got okay.
Well my question was about the mainstream media in the beginning.
You talked about you were trying to keep up with the cycle,
but you guys couldn't really keep up with a,
um,
just what are your thoughts about alternatives to mainstream media that,
that is telling some of these stories and more real time?
Um,
that's about that possibilities.
yeah,
I think alternatives to mainstream media are really,
really important.
I have not watched cable Knuth for really long time.
I don't get my news from there.
The only reason I really go to cable news,
it's to look at however it did kill with Lee.
They're portraying anything.
Um,
and so places like democracy now,
NPR,
Pro Publica,
I mean I'll just hire a AP.
There are a lot of places out there who tried to do really,
really good and actually balanced coverage because somehow balanced,
I think in the mainstream media has become conflated with bias toward the
establishment.
And like if you're not taking the establishment side,
then you're alarmist and your extremist and you're unbalanced.
And so it's a very weird media scape out there in the cable world.
And I really recommend that people find those other sources and also find who
are the activists and organizers and grassroots folks that you like and trust.
And if you pay attention and do a little quick,
I'm sure I don't have to tell anybody here how to use the internet,
how to move past that,
but you know,
find the sources that you can trust and you know,
they're out there and we kind of,
it's kind of,
I feel like in this strange middle phase,
you kind of have to get your news guerrilla style because I don't trust the,
the corporate outlets too much.
Thank you know this person.
Hi.
Saba.
So proud of you.
So going Sarah Ferguson was like one of the most,
um,
memorable experiences of my life and I was just there for a couple of days.
So every time I see you talk about this film and see how you've created
something that will last forever to educate,
so many,
I just get teary eyes.
So thank you for being here.
Thank you.
So question just,
I mean,
in terms of your goals with the film,
um,
you know,
I know this is so enlightening to so many people seeing this,
but you know,
how does it feel when we know there's still so much work to be done?
Um,
so I'm on you all's mailing list,
you all email out about,
you know,
um,
other injustices all over for Charlottesville most recently and other things,
I guess,
you know,
creating this,
um,
how do you continue to keep going,
you know,
in the fee knowing that things aren't going to change immediately.
Um,
so I'm really interested in like your self care and how you keep going,
uh,
with promoting this given just
right now.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Um,
that's a really good question.
And I had a really,
I've had a really hard,
like last two weeks,
I remember I was on Twitter and this is something that I had said in some
interview.
I said like,
you know,
I do this even though it hurts a lot of the time because it's better than being
numb.
And then I see this quote get published with a tweet.
And I was just like,
I do.
I even really feel that way.
Like this is really a lot and really painful.
But I have to remember though that there's something egotistical about that.
There's something a little self centered about that way of thinking.
Um,
because it was never my responsibility to change the whole entire world.
And Life is not a movie where,
you know,
you make the right choices and then everything is magically okay.
Um,
nobody saves the world.
We either all do or it doesn't get saved.
And so it's really about,
for me,
humbling myself to that and,
and really completely accepting the limitations of my power as an individual and
putting my trust and my hope and my faith in my community and the people that I
care about and the people around me.
And that's an every day constant remembering process cause everything conditions
us to believe that we can be problem solvers.
We can be the leaders,
we can do it if you just,
anything is possible.
But you know,
when it comes down to this,
I think that's when the limitations of reality really,
really hit you.
And so figuring out how to be a part of this and how would it be satisfied and
how to feel fulfilled and how to not be constantly traumatize knowing that
there's only so much that I can do.
Um,
that's everyday struggle.
That's the personal growth.
That's,
you know,
that's just the constant battle of it.
I don't think that there is any way out of it.
Um,
but I just recognize the fact that everything is not in my power.
I can only control what I control,
how many people I can reach.
And it's funny though because in sort of surrendering to that,
I've been able to reach more people than I've really ever thought was possible
there or knew that I could.
So it's interesting,
I mean I think it's just a little bit of faith.
It's a little bit of faith and,
and,
and humility and just kind of trying to be,
so does end about it and know that it's okay if I work is just a drop in a
bucket.
Even if I don't see anything.
Or if one little girl comes up to me and as a young film maker and thinks she
can do it,
like that's good,
that's,
that's satisfactory.
Having these people who lived through this to see this and say,
this reflects what I went through,
that's enough.
And the rest of it I think is this sort of,
you know,
it's all wrapped up in society and identity creation and who am I am a leader,
am I making a difference?
All these kinds of questions.
But we don't ever know the outcome of our lives.
We don't ever get to see the full ripple effects of what we do at while we here
on earth.
We just have to believe that it matters.
Thank you.
I would definitely describe feeling shaken from watching the movie.
It was great.
I'm curious,
and you,
I think you were kind of touching on this and maybe it's more just your,
I'm still thinking through,
but what are you going to do next?
Does it,
you kind of are starting to describe yourself as a filmmaker as it make another
film or go back to med school.
Yeah,
no,
I'm letting my house myself off the hook for med school.
I kind of like,
I took the,
so you get three years for this course.
I'm,
I right,
two years.
Biggest on announce out where you're going to med school.
So I'm not doing that.
Um,
I'm actually writing a fiction series,
which is still very new and fresh.
So when I say too much about it,
but,
um,
I want to go into some fiction because I think you can do some really,
really powerful storytelling when you have that freedom.
But also just to be of a lightened up a little bit.
Like it's a lot,
you know,
these are all real people whom I love very much.
So I don't know that I'm ready just yet to make a whole nother family.
Um,
so I want to get into some fiction and I want to tell stories that really
I always want to be in working in the private.
I want to bring the political into the private and think about the ways that
these things,
you know,
play out for us.
I want to explore those questions about feminism and that achy feeling as a
woman of being in charge,
having to be in charge of getting to be in charge of how have you think of it.
I want to explore these things in the ways that are small and,
and universal and recognizable to us because I think that,
you know,
while the stream of politics is moving and while all that change has to be
happening,
it has to be pushed for,
there's a spiritual evolution that also has to be taking place inside
individuals and households in the hearts and minds.
Um,
and I think all of that work is part of one stream.
So that's where I started seeing myself.
Okay.
Hi,
thank you so much for coming.
Um,
I apologize if this question's already been asked.
I got here a little bit late,
but I think one thing that I'm hearing you say especially about means media is
that like,
we just don't and can't trust it because the entire industry has been corrupted.
The issue that I have,
um,
is sort of that they're all right and sort of just like the right wing side
feels the exact same way about mainstream media,
but instead of seeking out sources that speak truth,
they go to like the Donald reddit pages and Breitbart and like sources like that
that are honestly just complete fiction and it has completely skew their reality
of the world.
How do you sort of like take truth and penetrate those audiences that also don't
trust mainstream media,
but like they responded to that like,
did mistrust in a completely different way?
Um,
that's a really good question.
I remember I was looking up the fake news epidemic and there was a thing on NPR
with a guy who had started fake news sites and he talked about how he targeted
them toward the right because people on the left didn't really buy them.
Um,
and so,
okay,
I think I understand why you grab onto the mistrust of media as a common
denominator and perhaps the jumping off point.
But I think that the,
the,
the most important factor here is confirmation bias.
And it's something that we all probably participate in every day.
It's something that we need to really watch out for.
Um,
getting into that echo chamber and responding to information that validates your
beliefs and believe in that information must be more true because you already
believed that.
Um,
but I think the difference between the right and left is that,
at least on the surface,
our values are about,
you know,
positivity and sharing.
They're not about this being for one particular set of people.
So when you have confirmation bias plus an preexisting bias about people,
you know,
that's a recipe to spiral down into a rabbit hole of misinformation.
So,
um,
I don't know how you tap into that.
I think that news and information should probably be regulated in some way,
but it feels like a really scary time to think about asking for any sort of
regulation.
Um,
and you know,
I certainly can't walk into some meeting or bar and be like,
hey,
you should check out democracy now.
I don't know.
So,
um,
I kind of am like,
I'm very much,
um,
about starting small and I think that I want to see what we can do.
You know,
I want to see what happens if everybody in my spear actually gets on the same
page and does something tangible,
um,
and moves past the point of sort of talking about what we should do and actually
starts to do something.
Maybe it's leading by example,
maybe it's showing what it looks like to be in community,
when be it's showing what this new world looks like and how inclusive it can be
and how positive it can be and allowing people to take that on for themselves.
You know,
I'm not sure,
but
in the spirit of maximizing the time,
I've got one last question.
Okay.
Um,
here at Google we talk a lot about what it means to be an ally.
You talked about your camera man,
and in his ability to do things and have conversations that you were unable to
have in moving spaces that you are unable to.
Can you talk about what it means to be an ally?
Or if someone said,
how can I be a better ally?
What would be your answer to that question?
Um,
I don't believe in allies.
I think that,
you know,
a couple of years ago when Obama first got elected,
we were talking about being post racial.
A lot of people say saint people who wouldn't be allies with saying,
I don't see color.
I just see people as human beings.
I just love everybody.
Well,
if you love everybody,
the not your brother getting shot down in the street,
that's your family,
that's your cousin.
You know,
that could be,
that's a reflection of you.
When I see somebody,
when I think about Sandra Bland,
I think about myself.
I feel like I died a little bit when I see Mike Brown and Tamir,
I'm scared for my cousins and so if we really are one human family,
then you should be scared like that too.
And if you're scared of like that too,
then there's no need for allyship then we're in this and that's how it was with
all of the white folks on my team,
particularly the ones who continue from beginning to end.
There was no question of allyship.
You know,
there may have been moments where we had to talk about this something.
You don't understand that something that you do,
but I looked up and we were shoulder to shoulder.
There was not time to talk about it.
There was nobody.
They were asking me,
what can I do?
How can I help?
They were putting their skills.
The rubber was hitting the road before I could blink.
And that's the kind of participation that white people need to be taken because
if we have to figure out,
okay,
what do these shoots going to do?
Where are you going to do what?
When do we have time for self care?
What do we have time to heal?
When do we have time to actually look at the internal issues that we have with
Danelle?
When do we have time for anything if we have to also problem solve for other
people and I think that,
you know,
I've grown up,
grown up,
lived around my people my whole life or most of my life.
Brilliant,
brilliant people,
very much,
you know,
with all the access to education and culture and all these things,
deep critical thinkers like I know so many brilliant white folks and then when
it comes to this all problem solving goes out the window and I know it's out of
discomfort.
I know it's out of uncertainty and not wanting to do the wrong thing,
but that's what happens when the rubber hits the road.
You fuck up,
you make mistakes.
You say the wrong thing,
it gets awkward,
it gets weird.
That's anything probably that we've ever done and do well.
By this time.
There was probably a point where we were bad at it.
We were awkward at it.
You know,
everybody has a car accident at some point.
Everybody has a weird date.
This is no different.
And so I just challenge people to step up and not just relinquish their capacity
and their agency and their involvement because it's uncomfortable and so
stressful and so weird.
There's all these feelings and guilt around it,
but it's,
we don't have time to be gradually pulling people along like jump in.
We're all human beings.
This is happening to us.
You know?
I think when we take that framework and be really honest,
not to say that,
you know,
if you're white,
you noticed to be black,
not to make assumptions would be really honest and look to see how this is
affecting you and how you know you're actually centered in it.
Like take your own stance kind of thing.
Because I also don't like feeling like somebody fighting on my behalf.
I feel like I'm fighting for everybody.
I feel like I'm fighting on your behalf.
So how,
you know what I mean?
So yeah,
that's,
that's my stance on it.
I think.
I like for people to just get their hands dirty about it.
I respect somebody who will make a mistake trying over somebody on the sidelines
asking me what to do.
Thank you for joining us today.
[inaudible].